hey everybody back with the Steven
universe V logs uh sadly Rob is not here
on this one and he probably won't be for
the next like three or four he had to
head out of town he's seeing family as
well um so yeah I'm just gonna do the
next couple here hopefully nothing huge
happens uh that he would miss but he's
gonna catch up with him anyway uh so I
made to talk about watermelon Steven
yeah I wasn't this fucked up this was a
yeah very bizarre kind of messed up
episode so um Steven and his father they
just start spitting watermelon seeds you
know just having fun hanging out and it
turns out all the watermelons sort of
grow these mini hims these mini Steven
watermelons that you buy what about
standards they're pretty big although I
don't know some can get really fucking
you but you get the idea they're these
watermelons Stevens that pop up and he
thinks they're just watermelons so he
doesn't know what to do so he just
decides to sell them and a lot of people
buy them but that turns out they're
alive and this little baby one comes to
life after being stolen by onion I swear
to fuck what is wrong with this kid it's
just an evil little kid I don't like him
if he's even that guy thing he's a kid I
don't know what is he what's his story I
just don't like him um but anyways is
baby
Steven melon comes to life and he
realizes that the others will come to
life so he goes and tries to collect
them all and he realizes they're kind of
hostile and kind of violent so the gems
pick up on this and they think Stevens
and dangerous and they try attacking the
gems he doesn't know what to do because
you know the gems are slicing up these
melons like fake time um and yeah so the
baby
Steven melon decides to punch Steven in
the gut knowing that all the are
watermelons will attack him and not her
the gems so it does that it sacrifices
itself Steven tells them all to go
become their own melons and think about
what they've done one of them gets
picked up by a seagull and then Steven
eats the remains of baby melon you pre
screwed up
um the China thing were to even start
with this
uh all right so these well first of all
the connection to the melons and like
the and how can he do this they explain
of his mother always sort of used plants
to come to life she could bring plans to
life and they always fought they were
fighting plants uh so these kind of
obviously do the same thing they're
trying to do it for a good cause but
they get confused I guess they're only a
few minutes old what can you expect
um but once again is something Rob was
kind of bringing up and I'm kind of
agreeing more and more is the the thing
with the gems is that their answer to
everything is just kind of violence or
at least anything kind of from their
universe like in terms of the stuff on
earth you know like that seems to be
like okay try to be kind of you know
nice and talk it out and be civil and
stuff but anything that has to deal with
like their universe or their world
they're like destroy it which is still
so interesting and they you know just if
they didn't push Stephen back in and
they tried to communicate with them and
talk to him it probably would have been
avoided and that's something that
Stephens always talking about he Sankey
and we talk about it can't we you know
discuss it and figure this out and yeah
I'm it's it's feeling more and more like
it's intentional that sort of the
difference between the gems and Stephen
is that he's much more of a passive is
he's the peacekeeper he wants to talk
things out he doesn't want to fight
unless he has to
and with the gems it seems like they
feel like they have to fight like they
maybe they've trusted things before
certain people before anything from
their universe is just not to be trusted
and it's it's leaning towards they're
not right um but I'm sure like down the
road those show like why these aren't
had this attitude to everything okay cuz
they're not like terrible people and
they're not mean it's like just sort of
a tough love thing and sometimes you
need tough love but it's like it's their
answer to everything so I'm curious if
they're ever really gonna address that
or if this is something that's going on
because it feels like it's going on
feels like they're kind of setting this
up that Stephen always tries to take the
peaceful route and they always take the
violent route at some point that's gonna
hit
kind of big head it's gonna explode or
something um and I'm curious out it
feels like that's the direction it's
going maybe it's just I'm reading too
deep into it but I'll know with all the
creatures they destroy and then like
whatever get their essence or gems
whatever and then banish them and stuff
like that like it
we saw one is you know like this cute
little dog you know that almost got
turned over we saw one as like this
woman in this mirror that you know from
the sound of it kind of sounded unfair
um you know against even took the
peaceful route with that but we don't
know if that's gonna turn out okay so I
don't know or maybe maybe it's like
there is no clear answer maybe it's oh
you just got played you know situation
to situation and both of them trying
this extreme one that's always peace one
one that's always violent you know you
just got pick and choose I don't know
yet they they haven't been totally clear
but um yeah pretty much
tons of watermelon people died including
a baby watermelon um so very bizarre um
pretty violent - I mean there's a lot of
like these watermelons blowing up and
stuff like that apparently they have a
lot of $2 bills in this world - that was
very interesting um trying to think what
else
yeah just very very strange which I
guess I wouldn't expect anything else
out of this show but ya can have a dark
cryptic episode um it'll be interesting
to see if these watermelon people just
come back at any point actually that'd
be great like in the middle of an
episode or something they can't find a
way out they don't know what to do and
then just like Steven calls the
watermelon people and they just come
back after like all this time they'd
actually be really funny
um but yeah well we'll just see what
happens so uh pretty cryptic and screwed
up but creative um I thought was really
creative they just spits the seeds
everywhere and then just it all these
old watermelon people grow I like sort
of eating the whatever chewing out the
watermelon crown and stuff like that you
know a little touches like that I really
like
um so yeah have we seen the last of the
watermelon people we will see so um yeah
just see you on the next one see see if
baby baby watermelon comes back no sad
I'm sure he was delicious I miss Rob